[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on était en direct on
est avec vous c'est figaro live et on
attend bien entendu vos points de vue
faut-il êtes vous favorable à la
suppression de l'ena c'est la question
qu'on vous pose sur le site du figaro
depuis ce midi qu'on continue de vous
poser parce qu'on attend d'une minute à
l'autre les annonces des manuels macron
autour de ce sujet les annonces de cette
suppression annoncée sans attendre en
tout cas on vous pose la question et on
va en débattre ce soir avec vous et avec
sophie de menthon bonsoir sophie vous
diriger le mouvement patronal ethic je
regarde mes notes parfaites je sais que
vous irez g le mouvement patronal ethic
et que chaque année à l'automne il y à
la journée j'aime ma boîte et déjà on
commence tôt 1 2 jamais on n'en fera
jamais assez que sophie merci en tous
les cas d'être avec nous et avec nous
avec vous le retour d'adrien batum
bonsoir adrien journaliste à marianne et
marianne qui revient qui promet cette
semaine de vous révéler tout ce que vous
ne savez pas encore sur la colline dix
neuf et surtout avec adrien vous pouvez
savoir tout ce qu'il faut savoir sur les
raisons de la chute de mélenchon et de
la france insoumise son livre est
absolument à lire si vous intéresser aux
sujets et il faut s'intéresser au sujet
il faut dire ce livre il est aux
éditions du rocher
ce qui fait débat encore aujourd'hui si
j'en juge par le nombre de commentaires
que vous avez laissé sur le site du
figaro sur le sujet c'est l'affront
commis par erdogan à l'encontre des
responsables de l'union européenne
ce qu'on appelle le sofa ou le divan
gates
ursula von der leyen la présidente de la
commission européenne qui a été donc
relégués sur un divan hier lors d'une
rencontre avec le président turc
une relégation contre tout protocole
alors fallait-il faire comme l'avait
fait adèle haenel adèle haenel aux
césars 2020 fallait il faire comme
l'avait conseillé virginie despentes
alors dans ce cas dit elle je cite on se
lève et on se barre ce n'est pas ce
qu'on fait des dirigeants européens
ont-ils eu tort ont ils eu raison
bah je vous propose d'en débattre mais
d'abord je vous le rappel vous pouvez
voter et continuez à voter sur le site
du figaro je vais éteindre le sont sur
mon ordinateur sinon vous avoir les
mille et une notification qui me
viennent en ce moment et qui sont autant
de commentaires que vous nous adressez
je vous salue je salue notamment zygo et
nicole qui nous rejoignent actuellement
sur le player du figaro je salue
également tous les internautes qui nous
rejoignent sur youtube
vous pouvez donc voter et continuez à
voter sur le site du figaro répondre à
la question du jour êtes vous favorable
à la suppression de l'ena vous êtes déjà
plus de cinquante mille à avoir voté
pour l'instant quand on a fait une
première un premier canton à jeter un
premier coup d'oeil sur les réponses à
ces questions on a vu que vous êtes une
majorité à être contre favorable à cette
suppression de l'ena sophie vous
approuvez 7,7
cette mesure cette mesure annoncée du
chef de l'état ça fait penser au
proverbe chinois quand le sage montre du
doigt la baisse il regarde le doigt
parce que là non pas du tout je serai de
présence à un public indécis loi delà
des soins de sage peut-être je trouve
que si on veut supprimer l'ena c'est
parce qu'il ya un dysfonctionnement
évident que nous avons les mêmes élites
que nous avons une reproduction d'une
technostructure et d'une administration
terrifiant dont on a parlé ici et on en
parlera jamais assez et j'ai presque
envie de dire que supprimer l'ena
pourquoi pas intéressant de signaler qu
aujourd'hui à 80 % d'élèves étrangers
c'est une réputation dans le monde
entier formidable ils viennent se former
en france donc c'est quand même une très
bonne école le problème c'est d'avoir
mis
le même moule les mêmes élites aux
postes de direction
alors je me fiche complètement qu'on
supprime les n'a aujourd'hui pas ce que
ça va donner des résultats dans combien
de temps il ya ceux qui sortent à la
prochaine promotion et qui deviennent
importants dans 10 ans ou dans quinze
ans est en revanche on continue à nommer
des énarques le président de la
république est entouré dé marquer les
lisiers y'a que ça lui même et marque
luminarc mais ça personne n'est parfait
mais il pourrait commencer par virer les
énarques les mettre ailleurs prendre des
gens de la société civile entre
guillemets parce que j'ai presque
l'impression que les énarques sont pas
les sociétés civiles les entreprises est
un monde un peu étrange
ils ont les photos de promo ou tombent
dans les bras les uns des autres
c'est amusant d'ailleurs puisqu'on va
parler tout à l'heure de l'ambassadeur
en france de turquie qui faisait les
nanas la même promotion que présente la
république sur votre sur votre de votre
point de vue la suppression de l'ena
c'est une bonne idée c'est une mauvaise
idée
mauvaise idée mais ceci dit c'est un
petit peu de la poudre aux yeux parce
que on supprime l'ena mais l'état
toujours besoin de cadres a placé à sa
tête et donc il y aura
ça va être assez probablement une
nouvelle école c'est juste que les gens
ont tellement détesté au fur et à mesure
du temps le sigle et n'a que emmanuel
macron j'étais un petit peu en pâture
l'ena à la vindicte populaire est ce que
dit effectivement un internaute sur
justement le site du figaro dans l'est
en réaction aux commentaires
à la question du jour je vous le
rappelle faut-il y êtes vous favorable à
la suppression de l'ena et cet
internaute 10 la suppression de cette
école est une pure opération de
communication il s'agit de montrer au
gilet jaune qu'ils ont été entendus
alors que l'existence de l'ena n'était
pas leur problème
réaction d'ailleurs de cet internaute
c'est un bel exemple de populisme à la
mode macro
moi je dirais plutôt démagogie populisme
mais des macros fait un petit peu ça sur
un autre thème c'est à dire que vous
avez de la part de l'entourage des
venets macron des fuites orchestrées
dans la presse qui disent que le
président extrêmement en colère contre
son administration pour des kwassas
c'est vrai type l'attestation et c'est à
mon avis c'est un petit peu facile de ce
délit
j'ai vu ça de près il est très en colère
il pique des colères et pas un tabac il
est très en colère alors que c'est même
lui qui décide donc au nom non alors
alors malheureusement j'ai peur que le
président ne décide plus quand il veut
vraiment quelque chose de précis et sert
à ça mais un mois on passe par les
circuits habituels etc et des sites sur
les grandes décisions
mais s'il veut faire quelque chose dans
les médias etc
c'est bloqué l'état profond il l'a lui
même il y en a parlé mais j'avais une
question adria vous dites il y aura une
autre école de pensée qu'il faut
vraiment une école pour l'administration
parce que sinon on s'en sort pas alors
c'est bien parce que ça nous permettent
directement d'aborder le débat de fond
alors justement peut-être avant
d'aborder malades faute d'avoir deux
grammes de point de vue en plus des
vôtres en plus des internautes que nous
attendons le point de vue de deux
personnes qui à ma connaissance ne sont
pas énarque bruno retailleau et françois
bayrou alors contre la suppression de
l'état contre la suppression de l'ena
bruno rôti on supprime l'ena pour ne pas
avoir réformé d'état qui est dit
privilège qui failli mettre fin à des
privilèges parce que parfois on en crée
en france des allées et venues entre le
public le privé où on retrouve davantage
oui mais on a besoin d'une élite l'ena
n'est pas le problème français le
premier français c'est de la réforme de
l'état
c'est très mac revient quand on prend un
bouc émissaire on prend une position
bouquet bis ne changera rien du tout qui
ne changera rien du tout on a besoin
d'élites et j'ajoute une chose c'est que
je suis pour la méritocratie
républicaine
républicaine dit bruno retailleau alors
françois bayrou lui et aussi pour la
méritocratie républicaine en tout cas il
le prétend il a toujours prétendu mais
il ne verrait pas d'un mauvais oeil la
suppression de cette école comme il l'a
laissé entendre ce matin sur france info
ou l'escalier l'ascenseur je ne suis pas
certain qu'ils puissent marcher
aujourd'hui comme il a marché
quand je suis entré dans cette dans ce
chemin là je trouve qu'aujourd'hui les
choses sont beaucoup plus bloquer
beaucoup plus un dur et l'état a connu
une dérive l'état est devenu
administration et l'administration est
devenu bureaucratie et ce système là que
cette mécanique là qui s'imposent
perpétuellement ça les blogs alors je
voyais rire et opiné pendant que
françois bayrou parle elle partage son
point de vue oui oui mais c'est terrible
l'état ne veut plus rien dire ça veut
dire administration ça veut dire
bureaucratie et franchement saluons
cette pandémie
les français s'en rendait pas vraiment
compte mais attention à ce que vous
dites mais je pense que c'est du
deuxième degré je me permets de vous le
dire parce que sinon certains esprits
malveillants vont vous vont découper cet
extrait et le site et je suis pour le
coronavirus et ça non je dis que saluer
cette pandémie qui a fait prendre
conscience franchement il y avait un
dysfonctionnement terrible qui avaient
des lobbys qu'il y avait un ministère de
la santé qui qui qui était englué avec
des comités des associations des agences
régionales de santé y en a 40 qui disent
qu'ils contrôlent pour ne rien contrôler
donc c est un vrai vrai problème je
pense que françois bellot un réseau
simplement il n'a jamais été capable de
faire quoi que ce soit y compris quand
il était au ministère de l'économie
nationale qui est quand même assez de
revenus de genre de l'éducation
nationale qui est quand même très
symptomatique de cette bureaucratie et
justement j'ai été auditionné à
l'assemblée nationale hier pour savoir
ce qu'il fallait faire elle après pour
les entreprises la préco vide
l'après kravitz et les missions
régaliennes de l'état un état garant pas
un état gérant
libéré et la libérer les fonctionnaires
il faut qu'à fonctionnaires il est des
chances de promotion il faut qu'ils
aient des primes faut qu'ils soient
récompensés quand il bosse bien
il faut qu'à 40 ans il n'ait pas atteint
son maximum il faut supprimer le statut
de fonction publique pour les nouveaux
entrants il faut le faire moi je
voterais pour le candidat quel qu'il
soit d'où qu'il vienne qui aura un plan
pour réformer pas l'état c'est pas ça
pour supprimer cette bureaucratie et
cette administration vous allez voter
pour 2010
oui je sais pas j'ai voté pour plusieurs
personnes au fur et à mesure parce que
j'avais des primaires il y avait failli
on a énormément votée mardi
j'ai fini par voter pour ma tronche au
premier tour de l'élection
je me souviens plus si j'ai été poli au
premier tour ah oui d'accord c'est la
question c'était le sens de ma question
oui c'est ça que je veux tu pollues
hossegor en tout cas ma vie j'étais pour
emmanuel macron mais j'étais partagé au
début j'avais trouvé que fillon avait un
programme bouquet extra ordinaire là
j'ai déchanté violemment ensuite j'avais
un certain attachement à sarko donc si
vous voulez j'ai été refaites les
primaires de 2012 mais mon coeur balance
et les manuels mais qu'on n'était pas
dans ses primes non il était passé près
adrien
le 2 au niveau de ce que dit justement
sofia calmes et dans ce que dit françois
bayrou il ya un problème aujourd'hui et
qu'a révélé sans doute la crise en tous
les cas c'est ce que sophie et françois
bayrou prétendent qu'ils et sept sur
administration et il convient peut-être
d'y porter remède dans tous les cas
c'est comme ça que l'élysée vent les
annonces que doit faire d'une minute a
lot to président de la république alors
oui il va sur sa déjà deux choses la
réforme de l'ena n'a absolument rien à
voir sur ministre à sion
c'est un autre sujet et ensuite alors je
sais que on en parle énormément dans
cette émission mais je ne pense pas
qu'on puisse résumer les mots de la
nation à la présence trop envahissante
de la bureaucratie
sauf à penser que pendant l'âge d'or des
trente glorieuses il n'y avait pas de
joux de bureaucratie ce qui est
absolument faux
moi j'ai une opinion totalement
différente considère ce lot dit c'est
que vous démentez paquet de la
bureaucratie oui route du rock bien sûr
mais me dit que ça serait si les
problèmes par la lgv est provoquée par
des facteurs toute façon voilà oui
perso si personne ne va dire oui il sait
tout va bien et il n'y a pas de problème
de survie nistration etc ça existe pour
les entreprises c'est majeur sans doute
alors ceci dit j'ai un avis radicalement
différent sur l'ena et sur la haute
administration qui est que je pense que
la crise de la haute fonction publique
depuis environ une quarantaine d'années
elle est due en fait exactement au
prennent inverse et que en fait on a
trop confondus publics et privés et que
alors peut-être que sophie est d'accord
avec ça mais en gros on a encouragé les
allers retours entre le public et le
privé pourquoi les hauts fonctionnaires
connaissent davantage le monde de
l'entreprise on a mis en place qu'en
parce que ce que beaucoup de chercheurs
appellent le new public management en
france une nouvelle gestion publique qui
consiste à penser en fait que la manière
de gérer un service public une
administration doit se rapprocher des
méthodes du privé
ces méthodes qui a été mise en place en
france y est sûr que oui et apprises à
l'ena mais qui a pris à l'ena depuis 40
ans et après bien sûr que si et en fait
justement c'est un peu ce que je veux
dire avec un petit peu de soleil est
peut-être aujourd'hui c'est que je suis
totalement
d'accord je pense qu'on ne gère pas un
service public qui a qui doit être
guidée par l'intérêt général comme une
entreprise qui devait être une idée par
le profit c'est même ça ça va tu remets
mme je ne pense pas qu'on gère un
hôpital une école un ministère comme on
gère une entreprise générant ce pardon
mais guardiola là vous vous trompez
alors là où vous avez raison c'est que
ce n'est pas supposé être profitable
c'est pas pour ça que ça doit être mal
géré ses semblables à ceux des c'est
l'état qui doit décider des menus de
laver les draps et les paddocks
l'hôpital a fini par déléguer au privé
des tâches qui étaient matériel au
départ l'hôpital devait tout faire
l'hôpital fonctionne comme le prix vu
depuis vingt ans on voit là au nom une
charge administrative à l'hôpital qui
est considérable je crois qu'il ya à peu
près je vais pas me tromper dans les
chiffres mais 40% des administratifs
pour 60% de soignant ses 20%
d'administratifs en allemagne pour les
soignants donc la réponse sinon je vais
vous donner un exemple mais vous parlez
du management mois alors parlons du
management alors parlons du management
exactement sophie parce que ce qui est
intéressant c'est que l'annoncent qui
ferment macron les au cours d'une
conférence de management de l'état
sophie d'angleterre si j'avais la terre
mais c'est le régime
il s'est posé à éviter donc des masses
et des managers plutôt que les hauts
fonctionnaires ça ça doit vous plaire
oui alors maintenant qu'est ce qu'on met
sous le terme de manager vous prétendez
kalenna en forme des managers
d'abord moi j'ai envie de dire pas trop
explicite patron patron chef
d'entreprise n'importe quelle structure
où il ya une hiérarchie où il ya des
gens à gérer de l'efficacité ça
s'appelle du management bien trouver un
autre mot français je suis d'accord mais
on a une idée du management pseudo
américains font une fausse idée à patron
dans un hôpital c'est celui qui est
capable de faire attention à la façon
dont on ne remplit pas quatre fois le
même dossier à l'accueil
danton gère dont on fait attention au
personnel soignant le personnel soignant
pendant la première crise
ma belle fille en faisait partie à
l'hôpital du kremlin bicêtre a dit
maintenant ça suffit à tous les
administratifs
on prend mal hôpital d'un coup de force
ils n'arrivaient plus le le management
d'entre eux y mais qui n'en est pas un
les administratifs ont dit d'accord on a
changé bouleversé ils ont changé les
salles changer l'élite place modifié
l'accueil modifier les urgences tout
repris en main ça fonctionne du feu de
dieu était enchanté ça s'est arrêté là
crise ils administratif est revenue plus
adroits de faire quoi que ce soit c'est
effectivement qu'on a eues mais c'est la
même chose pour discréditer le service
public et l'état
on en fait des caisses sur
l'administration et le résume l'état les
bureaux grâce au mans on résout ce
problème d'administration et
d'administratifs qui prend le pas sur le
coeur de métier parce qu'il ya un point
sur lequel il me semble que vous êtes
d'accord c'est que deux institutions
partiel vous attachez vous d'importance
que vous exprimez beaucoup d'attachement
l'école et l'hôpital
on dénonce dans ces deux institutions
une administration qui prend le pas sur
le coeur de métier
comment on résume ça je pense qu'on
résout pas tout simplement en regardant
un petit peu quels sont les postes
superflu et qu'ils les gardent à mon
avis qu'ils regardent qui va regarder
quelqu'un on n'a jamais trouvés dans les
tapis regarde mais ceci dit ce qui
détruit l'hôpital
c'est une précisément tous tout ce qui
est prôné comme des pseudo solutions
c'est-à-dire la le faire fonctionner en
pensant qu'en fait quand on gère un
service public en pensant que les
citoyens sont des clients et ça c'est un
peu ça ce que vous avez décrit en disant
oui il faut bien prions de l'état mois
ben non on n'est pas client de l'est
mais si je suis client gaullien je paie
suffisamment cher non non un problème
est en fait le
c'est peut-être la con auquel un
désaccord c'est que depuis 40 ans moi je
pense aussi qu'il ya des gens à l'état
alena qui pensent exactement comme vous
qui ont théorisé le fait que l'état
était quelque chose de absolument
détestable et il fallait ce sont des
gens qui ne servent pas ça le problème
de l'état
c'est vous regardez il ya eu beaucoup
dans quel journalistique sur le sujet
pour être pris à l'ena quand on passe le
concours il faut absolument dire qu'on
souhaite réduire la part de l'état qu'on
souhaite soutenir la construction
européenne et qu'on soutient le
libéralisme
donc après venir nous expliquer que la
profession de foi libérale qui ai
demandé à bien sûr aimé recevoir ça
c'est pour le coup c'est documenté il ya
le regard d'elena alors bas vous sonnez
voilà mais c'est vrai il faut il faut
pas il faut pas afficher sa courbe il
faut pas afficher sa foi en l'état et
envers le modèle social français si on
veut rentrer à l'ena mais c'est quand
même de nombreuses enquêtes
journalistiques des témoignages
d'énarques qui dans tous les cas dans
leur réserve et anciens sur le palais
dans l'exercice libero l'exercice à 5 6
dans l'exercice
dans les convictions ils le sont
peut-être mais dans l'exercice en tant
que telle ou ne s'applique pas si
libéralisant réalité c'est là qu'on
touche la réalité du néolibéralisme et
non pas du libéralisme
c'était ça la différence c'est que le
néolibéralisme mais l'état au service du
marché c'est à dire que l'état existe il
est même il peut même être puissant et
avoir beaucoup de 20 ans pas puissant
mais comment dire pléthorique il
fonctionne au service du marché
par exemple le csio on a un très bon
exemple les réformes de leur travail par
exemple la réforme de l'hôpital en est
un excellent exemple
c'est à dire que vous avez pas vous
n'avez pas comme comme le dit comme le
théorise les libéraux classiques une
réduction du rôle de l'état mais un état
qui se met au service d'une logique
marchande et qui abandonne la logique du
service public sophie d'abord le service
public je le respecte infiniment je
pense que l'état on ne sait plus ce que
c'est on confond souvent avec la nation
d'ailleurs si vous avec la bureaucratie
ou avec le bureau baresi et c'est vrai
que oui oui l'état est devenu synonyme
de bureaucratie donc je ne sais pas ce
que c'est le sens de l'état on sait plus
très bien ce que c'est on n'a pas eu des
exemples formidables et je ne comprends
pas pourquoi pourquoi vous avez cette
détestation d'une efficacité et d'une
rentabilité jeu c'est vrai que entendre
et non avec des oui rentabilité mehdi
salmi mimant table dont elle a servi
sauf si alors bon il peut être avec ses
médias est trop comme ces deux choses
différentes
alors l équilibre mais ni l'un ni
l'autre ne sont des objectifs mais quand
même on n'a pas su poser avoir des
l'objectif faire de l'argent n'est pas
l'objectif de l'organisation j'ai jamais
dit ça mais l'hôpital font son objectif
n'est pas d'être à l'équilibré être
rentable il est de soigner les gens oui
l'école doit être rentable c'est pareil
est-ce que les autres que se révèle son
pourquoi l'hôpital privé est formidable
et qu'on n'a pas voulu d'ailleurs ça
n'occupe et au début il était là avec
des lits de réanimation pourquoi est ce
que ça fonctionne
et pourquoi faudrait-il qu'ils ne sont
pas les mêmes objets qui sont pas les
mêmes en fait en tout cas tous les
enfants maintenant quand on a les moyens
vont dans le privé autrefois on allait
au lycée parce que vous avez parlé en
tous les cas de je note quand même que
en parlant de l'état vous avez par les
deux institutions qui ne sont pas
régaliennes à l'origine mais ce sera
peut-être l'occasion d'un autre débat
sur l'éducation et sur l'hôpital
peut-être que de voir si peut-être là il
n'y a pas une clé peut-être la réaction
rapidement de nicole qui nous dit c'est
la prolifération des énarques dans la
sphère du pouvoir qu'il faut arrêter
l'ena elle sera recréée sous un autre
nom est ce que cette affaire de
prolifération des énarques sphères du
pouvoir de l'état il faut l'arrêter
vraiment un côté aristocratie d'état qui
est évidemment délétère mais qui n'est
pas nouveau jean pierre chevènement
avait écrit en 67 les mandarins la
société bourgeoise pour parler de l'ena
donc c'était c'est quand même pas à
nouveau la question c'est bien connu de
l'initiation ramonet asri on les
remplace partie on les remplace et moi
je voudrais faire un sort à l'expression
société civile qui en fait désigne les
élites 2
du privé en fait la société civile c'est
toute la société qui est anormal c'est
que de la société civile
la société civile on en a beaucoup parlé
quand les camps les députés en marche
d'arriver à l'assemblée avait quand même
plus de drh et d'experts en marketing
que d'ouvrir dans le bâtiment donc la
société civile on voit s'il sahara mais
on voit ce que ça veut dire la société
civile si vous voulez c'est pas du tout
c'est une expression un petit peu vagues
allaient souffrir le bâtiment c'est la
société civile oui mais quand on dit
faire accéder la société civile au plus
haut niveau de l'état
ok on pense à mon choisy point sur sur
la prolifération des marques dans les
hautes sphères de louis-charles accord
mais voulait remplacer parcours alors
par des gens tout aussi efficace je veux
dire il faut être effectivement
probablement à ses diplômes et parce que
c'est compliqué complexe etc
les politiciens sont des gens très bien
hec ddd toutes les écoles de ceux qui
viennent de la fac
normale sup enfin je sais pas je suis
très fier on est d'abord français long
de la corde que tout que tous viennent
de la même école du même moule ces
problématiques et c'est ça qui est
problématique beaucoup de grandes écoles
françaises de qualité
on verra en tout cas une émission qui
ont un effet sur les décrypteurs sur la
question et vous avez notamment le
plaidoyer d'arnaud tessier qui est un
ancien élève de l'ena et qui est un
historien et qui a des arguments qui
sont assez intéressants sur le sur le
maintien de l'ena qui a montré comme
comment également l'ena pouvait être un
creuset qui évitait l'esprit de corps
à l'intérieur de l'intérieur de l'état
en est pour en est content mais en tout
cas c'est un éclairage intéressant et
j'espère que julie goutard le va réussir
à le retrouver pour le mettre dans le
chat et six mois on leur mettra dans les
dents les replays jeu ont déjà un petit
coup d'oeil notamment à la question
composé sur le site du figaro êtes vous
favorable à la suppression de l'ena et
c'était une nette majorité avant le
début de cette émission va regarder
juste si mon ordinateur veut bien suivre
si c'est toujours c'est toujours le cas
c'est assez long à venir et surtout il
nous reste plus que 10 minutes de débat
me rappelle dans l'oreillette que vous
ne voyez pas marie-amélie bauchet est
pour l'instant effectivement c'est la
même tendance à 61,60 5% à plus de
soixante deux mille à voter on peut
continuer à voter l'autre question qu'on
pose ce soir elles qui sont pour la
répression de l'ena l'autre question
qu'on vous pose sur twitter ce soir
concerne cette affaire qui fait couler
décidément beaucoup d'encre et qui
suscite pas mal de paul et beaucoup de
polémiques beaucoup de commentaires en
tout cas de votre part vous êtes plus de
2000 avoir réagi sur le site du figaro
et avoir commenté cette information
donc et les images qui ont fait le tour
de l'europe et la turquie sans doute
aussi où on voit
alors cela van der leyen relégué par
recep tayyip erdogan
non pas sur l'un des deux sièges que
l'on devient devoir mais sur le divan
juste à côté face au ministre des
affaires étrangères l'europe at elle
raison de ne pas condamner l'affront qui
oeuvrent café sur billère dogana charles
michel et et ursula von der leyen ça
c'est la question qu'on pose sur twitter
voici en tout cas avant d'avoir votre
vote d'avoir vos réponses d'avoir vos
commentaires le point de vue du
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes du secrétaire d'état
français clément bonne oui ce sont des
images qui font mal et qui manifestement
montre quelque chose d'organisé moi je
défends toujours l'europe mais je veux
pas d'une europe naïve fragiles et donc
là je crois que on a affaire à des
interlocuteurs
le président turc qui eux connaissent la
force des images la valeur des symboles
on doit être beaucoup plus ferme
beaucoup plus fort là dessus c'est un
affront corrigera mais il faut pas
laisser faire ce genre de choses ici
c'est honneur aux dames
donc c'est sophie de menthon qui va
réagir et qui va se dire nous dira si
elle a été convaincue par clément bonne
surtout vous qui connaissez
justement les questions de protocole
alors d'abord je me suis posé la
question qu'est ce que j'aurais fait et
je me vois très mal va se faire dans le
canapé
donc je pense que je pense que j'aurais
pris à témoin peut-être quelques
collègues en disant où est ma place
ça c'est une chose je crois que les
femmes doivent s'imposer parce que aussi
voilà elle s'est assise sagement sur le
canapé je comprends qu'elle ait voulu
privilégier une négociation terriblement
importante et qu'il fallait pas médecin
en avant mais quand même la deuxième
chose c'est les hommes qui étaient
autour d'elle excusez-moi basse et c'est
invraisemblable il aurait dû se lever et
le lui montrer la place soult dire
quelque chose sur le moment c'est ça qui
est invraisemblable
je pense que c'est nous qui avons
complètement tort les turcs n'ont fait
que se comporter comme il se comporte
d'habitude les femmes n'ont pas classe
les rangs de l'as pas serrer la main
ils ont un autre protocole fabron je
veux dire c'est que s'ils ont un autre
protocole mais on va voir des photos
justement qui sont révélés par une vague
qui sont rappelés parce qu'on les
connaissait sa part une eurodéputée
néerlandaise
les voilà donc on voit les
recep tayyip erdogan recevoir les
prédécesseurs de or cela van der leyen
et de charles michel à gauche de
d'erdogan on voit donald tusk dont qui
était le prédécesseur de charles michel
et à gauche d'erdogan on voit jean
claude juncker qui était le prédécesseur
d'ursula von der leyen
est ce là la preuve le premier cliché
date de 2017 et on voit bien que ils
sont tous les deux assis sur un siège
sur un dans un fauteuil
autour du président erdogan et même
chose deux ans auparavant en 2015 où on
les voit dans un fauteuil peut-être les
mêmes d'ailleurs mais pas ceux qui
avaient hier donc erdogan
il connaît bien si tu connais le proto
moi je dis mais l'école des turcs c'est
que les femmes sont pas au même niveau
c'est ça ce que je voulais dire c'est
que donc c'était tout à fait volontaire
ça correspond à l'attitude de la turquie
vis-à-vis des femmes ça correspond à ce
qu'on doit pas accepter en europe et
enfin pardonnez moi
l'europe doit absolument être unis et le
diable est dans les détails et je pense
que l'europe aurait dû faire corps
contre cette attitude alors là bien vous
disiez vous comprenez qu'elle ait pas
voulu réagir
elle a bien fait pas réagir ben moi
j'aurais réagi mais enfin bon je bien
fait je vais pas la juger je pense
qu'elle aurait dû réagir mais dut céder
encore une fois je critique pas il y
avait des enjeux incroyable oui mais on
regarder quelque chose vous parle
justement je vous parle de ça au regard
des enjeux qui sont eux qui sont qui
sont eux mêmes à falaise en jeu
justement elles étaient porteuses
d'enjeux dont la place des femmes
si tu as des enjeux majeurs quand même
il ya une autre réaction
adrien jeu comme entier celle d'eric
ciotti qui donc a réagi sur twitter qui
s'est indigné de cette scène et il dit
il appelle à la clôture définitive du
processus d'adhésion de la turquie à
l'union européenne
la question que j'ai envie de vous en
pensez moi je n'étais même pas au
courant qu'il était encore ouvert je
comprends pas qu'ils soient pas déjà
clos depuis longtemps mais pas pour cet
épisode pour d'autres beaucoup d'autres
justement est-ce que c'est pas une
occasion sans doute oui alors après je
ne pense pas que l'adhésion de la
turquie a lieu soit vraiment à l'ordre
du jour même si il a pour le coup c'est
intéressant de le souligner parce que
cette rencontre entre erdogan charles
michel et votre iphone rien ne s'était
pas du tout une rencontre placée sous le
signe de la tension on est des
l'objectif était je cite d'ouvrir un
nouveau chapitre dans les relations
entre l'europe et la turquie entre
l'union européenne et la turquie et
notamment il y avait pour projet de
faciliter l'accès de la turquie au
marché européen mais est à mon avis ça
explique peut-être aussi la réaction de
vos données indiquent un art book qui en
a besoin aujourd'hui
bien sûr en particulier d'expression et
monétaires étaient extrêmement lents et
puis elle subit des sanctions dégradé
des états unis mais pour le coup on est
dans votre côté de la balance est à mon
avis ça explique aussi peut-être
l'hésitation de von der leyen qui en
plus je pense jour une petite parenthèse
a dû être un petit peu s'y déroulent pas
forcément comprendre ça c'était vraiment
c'est que évidemment on allait en parler
mais la turquie a un pouvoir d'influencé
considérable sur l'union européenne
puisque on va donner on donne
actuellement 6 milliards d'euros par an
aux turcs et amber pressent à un moment
donné plus
poliseno les migrants si rien et pour
qu'ils les laissent pas rentrer en grèce
donc les turcs ont un moyen de chantage
considérable sur les européens et
j'ajoute à cela un dernier élément qui
est que ni vendeurs reviennent ni
charles michel ne sont des élus ils sont
des gens nommés et non pas évidemment la
même légitimité que erdogan
dans ce bras de fer donc la question par
rapport à ça c'est précisément étant
donné le contexte la question c'est est
ce que il faut absolument trouver
dans ces cas là un accord avec la
turquie s'attirer les bonnes grâces
d'ankara bien ne pas jouer le rapport de
force
le problème c'est que je vais peut-être
avoir l'air d'être un bon dans une
marotte mais à mon avis l'échelon
européen c'est un petit peu compliqué
sur ce sur ce bras de fer là pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce que les
pays européens ne maîtrisent pas leurs
frontières migratoires il forcément là
sont en position de faiblesse
parce que c'est compliqué de dire qu'on
peut jeter à l'eau l'accord si on n'a
pas la maîtrise de nos frontières de
l'autre côté et le deuxième élément
c'est que les européens ne sont pas unis
sur ce sujet puisque la dernière fois
qu'il ya une crise entre les pays
européens et la turquie cité en
l'automne dernier en novembre où il ya
eu les turcs qui faisait des opérations
en grèce qui ont beaucoup fâché les
européens il ya eu aussi la sphère de
erdogan qui nous accusent d'être
islamophobe
après la loi séparatistes et là les
allemands ont bloqué les demandes de
sanction de la france contre la turquie
donc les européens ne sont pas unis
encore une fois c'est facile de dire
l'europe doit répondre mais les
européens ne sont pas forcément unis
face à la turquie jeu sur ce point là
justement qu'est ce que vous pensez que
justement à la france je repose la
question
emmanuel macron lui a été sur une
tendance plus dur notamment par rapport
à la turquie est ce que doit se
désolidariser de l'allemagne et avoir
une danse plus dur je suis tout à fait
d'accord sur le fait que l'europe est
totalement désunis par rapport à ça ou
on veut une europe on veut pas d'europe
je pense que si l'urgence il faut se
regarder soi même il faut pas se
demander ce qu'on devrait faire il faut
se demander ce qu'on peut faire on peut
rien faire on leur donne de l'argent à
schengen ben voilà on leur donne de
l'argent pour qu'ils gardent les
migrants ils trouvent eux qu'on leur
donne pas assez d'argent du tout il faut
voir que la turquie est complètement
expansionniste et veut refaire l'empiré
ottoman que la cathédrale sainte-sophie
a été un symbole incroyable que la
religion c'est le nerf de la guerre que
ils se permettent de traiter angela
merkel de nazis et macro de marge et que
donc
comment tolérer ça mais c'est la
question comment tolérer ça et bien il
faudrait que l'europe se réunissent et
se disent maintenant stop on se serre
les coudes quoi qu'il arrive
mais toute façon on n'a pas la maîtrise
des frontières donc je pense que mon
fait alors moi mon point de vue sur sa
sueur au niveau du national
c'est que là on a beaucoup parlé des
intérêts parce que c'est très important
dans la diplomatie et les intérêts et
dans la géopolitique mais sur un plan
plus civilisationnel erdogan est un
ennemi oui même l'ennemi numéro 1 parce
que oui en dictateur oui il ne reconnaît
pas l'état de droit et d'ailleurs je
crois que la veille
rencontre avec les européens il a encore
fait arrêter deux amiraux qu'il
critiquait c'est un ennemi des femmes il
s'est quand même opposé à la convention
d'istanbul qui contrôlent plus leurs
sont saines et c'est un partisan de
l'islamisation
moi je me rappelle en 2015 on l'a laissé
faire un discours à strasbourg où il
s'est adressé en turc à la diaspora
turque qui vit en france en leur disant
que l'intégration c'était l'ennemi
absolu qu'il fallait pas s'intégrer et
qu'il fallait faire une communauté dans
la communauté
donc honnêtement c'est quand même et je
rappelle ses commentaires contre les
français contre la laïcité contre contre
l'universalisme français à l'automne
donc franchement honnêtement c'est de
s'éteindre
c'est un ennemi même seconde sur le plan
des valeurs mais totalement même un peu
la honte parce que soyons clairs on n'a
absolument pas le pouvoir de réagir aux
knicks humilié mais au niveau national
on devrait l'avoir le
donc la question composé sur twitter
rapidement vous me répondez oui non
l'europe at elle raison de ne pas
condamner la france qu'elle fait subir
chaque heure de ganache harmouche
ailleurs selon elle on était capable
mais elle a tort comment elle en est
incapable de le condamner mais elle a
tort par principe faut condamner quand
même et la caisse la réponse à la
question de l'auteur on va le voir si on
arrive à avoir la réponse est non on n'a
pas parce que justement on a des petits
soucis d'internet mais on avait en tout
cas les premières tendances et et que
l'europe avait tort et c'était aux
alentours de 2,81 à entre 80 et 90% vous
pouvez continuer à voter pour twitter
pardon de ce problème et pardon d'avoir
un peu dépassé le temps imparti mais
c'était très intéressant nous entendre
commenté et débattre c'est deux
événements merci beaucoup de nous avoir
suivi et on se retrouve demain même
heure même endroit avec jean christophe
buisson et laurent joffrin a très vite
sur figure au live
[Musique]